a little bit of a a situation that
unfolded last night and some of you guys
were privy to this
I had fun
I hope you guys had fun
but uh
you know last night I was watching uh
Davey Croco stream with wild smile
by the way two guys that uh I'm very big
fans of uh not only
um
but um we were having a little fun last
night
at the expense of uh Jeremy the
quartering and uh everybody was getting
in on this action I mean it was it
started with me [ __ ] with them and
Davey crock always fight with him and
Andy warsky jumped in and me and warsky
were going hard on him I think the
artist Ethan Ralph jumped in like it
just became this [ __ ] pylon of people
[ __ ] with the quartering
and honestly I it's it's
it's my fault I started it so it's
definitely my fault but like I didn't
even mean to
start whatever the [ __ ] I started right
I literally tweeted out one thing last
night I'm just trying to find it now uh
here it is
this was my tweet last night
this tweet okay for some reason started
World War Three on Twitter
um I was as I was saying I was watching
Davey Croco and wild smile too guys I
I'm fans of their work I'm also fans of
them as people uh very cool guys so you
know I like to support people and uh
support our friends so got done with the
show last night and you know Davey
crocko's live so you know I tweeted it
out and I'm like yeah I'll go pop in
I'll you know throw them a stream Labs
I'll watch a little bit before I go play
video games
and he's playing this clip of uh the
quartering
and I'm like he's not really wearing
this hat right so for those of you that
can see he's wearing a hat in his video
about this was about Tim pool
where his hat said uh meme War veteran
which this is like this was the
cringiest thing I've seen in a [ __ ]
long time
so I couldn't I couldn't resist
and I tagged him in this tweet and all I
wrote was bro
sweet hat that's
oh just not even going really hard on
the guy
not being that much of a dick just hey
bro
sweet hat because it's just just let the
thing [ __ ] speak for itself right
um
he's a maid
so I I couldn't let this in this [ __ ]
made me laugh so uh Andy warsky jumped
in saying my soul cringes
and then the quartering got really
pissed off at that and uh decided to
start yelling at warsky
a lot of you guys ended up getting
retweets from them though so that's um
so that's kind of funny but uh
so Andy warsky wrote my soul cringes the
quartering fired back getting roasted by
Andy warsky has never meant less I wish
you the best dude hopefully get your
life back on track ah the old taken the
high road attack gotta love that
taking the old High Road oh gee I wish
you the best I hope you get your life
back on track man
[Music]
so we all started busting his chops
worsky said his wife should divorce him
for that ad which that made me laugh
uh and dude he just started retweet sub
tweeting and replying to every
individual insult directed at him uh for
the better part of the evening last
night
I mean it was just non-stop like I said
I piled on Ethan Ralph piled on warsky
uh uh SoCal Chris
AG luck Travis I mean just everybody was
piling on this idiot and making fun of
his cat
and then of course the quartering says
oh yeah right his wife should divorce
him uh his wife who 12 years should
divorce him for wearing a hat their
mutual friend bought him for Christmas
so of course I had to say to him that uh
if my own mother came back from the dead
and gave me that hat as a gift uh I
would have to throw it in the garbage
immediately
that I would rather wear a hat that says
registered sex offender on it
um
so I don't does this guy does I don't
really watch the quartering like I I
talk to him a little bit when um
you know when the [ __ ] uh Magic the
Gathering [ __ ] was going on with the
pedophiles and I thought he did good
work there objectively I'm not going to
pretend retroactively uh like I didn't
think he did great work on that well we
covered that a little bit on our Show
when he started doing his thing I
thought it was you know I thought it was
good work outing people I thought his
motivation was pretty obvious
um
you know the only the only problem I had
with his stuff uh with the magic the
Gathering stuff it's like you know if
you knew all this stuff was going on uh
why did you wait until they kicked you
out before you went and ran to the Press
um
that's one of those things where like
you know I mean like so you knew that
there were all these pedos and they were
like conducting all these [ __ ]
tournaments or whatever with these kids
and you didn't care until they kicked
you out of the magic the Gathering
tournaments and they kept your money and
then you were like hey guys there's
pedophiles in there so that was like my
only issue with that but objectively
it's pretty gross that these people were
employing these disgusting folks so uh
you know we gave that some coverage
whatever but does he have any
self-awareness at all like I don't I
haven't watched him since then but uh it
just seems like he just sucks timple's
dick now and wears cringy hats but like
what is his
uh what is his problem bad news says he
hired PewDiePie's video editor to try to
get more views
um it's been fading from relevance since
the Monday Matt shitstorm yeah I mean
that's again though that's why you
really shouldn't rely on uh e drama
you know he these these guys um
now it's not just the quartering it's a
lot of these the blood Sports types of
people
um they rely way too much on the drama
itself
to keep people interested in their show
and in my opinion you should be focused
on being funny being engaging having
quality content building a good
Community like this you should be
focused on the content
and then when you get a moment of drama
capitalize on it get more eyes on your
show but you gotta you know when the
people just constantly do the drama
thing it kind of wears thin after a
while uh he's he's debating apparently
uh Tim Poole's brother right now on the
killstream I don't care look we're gonna
have uh Temple's brother on uh revenge
of the sis uh I believe this week coming
up he's gonna come on and tell his side
of the story so
um you know looking forward to hearing
that I'll be honest with you I think
both of the pool brothers are [ __ ]
cringe from being honest uh
um not just how I feel it but if this
guy has some dirt on Tim pool I'm all
about it right like I don't if I have to
pick a side I'm picking the non-tim
poolside
because he's a food Buck food bucket
Shilling uh uh chill basically and uh so
we're gonna have him on next week should
be um interesting and we'll see what he
has to say regarding this uh subverse
which by the way you guys are like I
think the cringiest thing about the pool
brothers fighting each other is the fact
that you guys are fighting over a.net
domain you know what I mean like holy
[ __ ] it's not even a.com
ah so I gotta I gotta loosen up my belt
a little bit I'm getting fat
um
they're fighting over a DOT net domain
which is really [ __ ] cringe to me
um but whatever they're they're
having their little battle and uh you
know look anything that exposes Tim
Poole I'm [ __ ] game for so hopefully
we'll uh get him on next week and he'll
have uh whatever he has to say but that
I just want to update you we had Jeremy
uh kind of freaking the [ __ ] out